for eight consecutive nights people in
Tehran have defied authorities to
protest over the death of Masa amini
the 22 year old died in custody last
week after being arrested by so-called
morality police she'd allegedly violated
the country's policy on headscarves
[Applause]
similar protests are spreading across
Iran in the Northwestern city of Ocean
Ave demonstrators defied a warning by
the Iranian Army that it would confront
what it called enemies of the state
similar protests were held in the
western city of karamabad Tehran has
limited internet services to clam down
on the growing descent the problem is if
they switch off the the access to
International networks to their global
internet then with the national internet
or the national Internet it's really
hard to use those VPN services safe
messenger apps such as signal the US
government has eased export restrictions
on software and some technology to Iran
to widen online access but analysts say
it's unlikely to have an immediate
impact
several demonstrations in support of the
government have also taken place in Iran
President Ibrahim rahisi says amini's
death must be investigated but is called
the protests acts of Chaos
they want to ride a wave and create
riots and disturbances they think with
such moves they can stop the nation we
have announced many times that if anyone
has a fair comment we will listen to it
but Anarchy disturbing National Security
the security of people no one will
succumb to this foreign
so far though the protests show no sign
of dying down
Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera